[Music]
in the january edition of spectator
world mary harrington says the pandemic
has not just revealed but widened class
divides the upper classes can jet off
like kim kardashian did to their own
private island and avoid it all and the
middle classes can work from their
laptops at home or an airbnb
the working class as low she writes have
been forced to keep on working in
restaurants bars and hotels
to discuss mary joins me now
mary for the spectators world january
edition you write a piece where you
begin by talking about a wedding what
was the significance of this wedding
it caused a significant stir across the
united states just for its sheer
extravagance
it was reported in the pages of vogue as
far as i can make out it went on for at
least three days um every single detail
of it was wildly expensive and wildly
curated i mean it was it was mesmerizing
it had a sort of mary antoinette energy
about it you know every every dress cost
thousands every detail of it was just
sort of wildly kind of
symbolic to a to a degree which is
unimaginable i think to most ordinary
people simply because that's just not
the world we live in you know we might
be able to choose whether to go to this
restaurant or that restaurant but the
idea of you know inviting a thousand of
your closest friends to a wedding party
or however many it was and then offering
them iv drips to deal with the hangover
at the after party picnic the following
morning
it was just a bit beyond most people's
normal frame of reference it was it had
a kind of end of
end of civilization kind of
hyper hyper wealthy decadence to it
which i think just struck a very strange
note at the end of a pandemic when a lot
of people have been going through some
really quite grim times
and this is a wedding involving ivy
getty and from the wealthy getty family
but in your piece you make the example
that this is uh you know a sign of how
covert is not just highlighted but
actually exacerbated class divisions um
in society can you talk us through um
almost the various parts of that because
there's one obviously the upper classes
you could call them but there's another
group which is perhaps one that probably
um more people watching this could uh
you know
compare their lifestyles to rather than
this wedding
so i
i outlined the ways in which ivy getty's
wedding and also the met gala which was
not long before that exemplified a very
stark division which has been more more
i think revealed than
revealed than anything else by the
pandemic which is to say asymmetric
rules on masking
it's now it's now routine for people who
are serving
others of higher status to remain masked
while people people who command higher
status whether permanently or
temporarily are exempt from that for
whatever reason and one example i gave
was ivagetti's wedding where the wedding
party and nancy pelosi who officiated
swept into the into the town hall at
which point all the all the attendees
all the guests ritually put their masks
on but the wedding party remained
unmasked you know the same was very
visible at the met gala photographs show
that the guests were unmasked but all
the serving people were masked in
uniformly and that was even visible at
the beginning of the pandemic when kim
kardashian tweeted from the private
island where she
arranged a get-together with all of her
extended family and they were all
pictured hugging and drinking and having
a lovely time while all of us were
locked down or you know saying goodbye
to our dying grandmas through the
nursing home window
um meanwhile there are serving staff in
the background collecting empties with
their masks on at kim kardashian's
private island so that's so much for the
aristocracy you know who who are as it
were permanently exempt from masking um
and masking i think stands as a kind of
symbol of status in this way you know
whether or not you whether or not you're
entitled to in-person human interaction
um the zoom class um i've sort of i've
tried to show how
if you're a member of the zoom class
which is to say people who people who do
knowledge work i class myself i suppose
as a member of that class i work
remotely you know i might i could take
my laptop and in theory work from
anywhere um
that class
is sometimes sometimes gets to enjoy the
the mask-free privileges of the sort of
kardashians of this world and at other
times don't and are also characterized
by being extraordinarily neurotic
about about infection control and i
cited as an example an
article in the atlantic
which reported a man going to a
different wedding
in new orleans
um where
he panicked all the way through about
the terrible riskiness of of interacting
in in a normal way mask-free despite the
fact that everybody who attended the
wedding parties was already vaccinated
and then as far as i could make out
absolutely freaked out when he caught
covered as a consequence of that and
hired an apartment down the road from
his family where where his children
would come and visit him sitting more
six feet or more away on the porch
wearing and wearing an n95 mask
which suggests a
fairly extreme degree of of anxiety
about contamination which to my eyes
will shades over from being
sort of strictly medical and rational
into something more like a sort of fears
for spiritual purity
and i would say this is this has become
increasingly characteristic of the zoom
class
and further down the food chain that
just simply isn't practically possible
because these are the people who are who
are serving you know in all of these
settings in people who
the people who collect rubbish bins or
do care work or whatever you know have
have done their best to manage infection
control but if you work with people on a
daily basis as your job and can't work
remotely it's just not possible to
become that neurotic about person human
contact it just isn't because you you
remain in contact with people
um just by virtue of the nature of your
work um
and i think
it's and what i really wanted to draw
out was
the the way the pandemic has has both
stratified those classes in a much more
extreme way because it's rendered it
it's not only rendered the divisions
more visible but it's also it's also
increased increased the the difficulty
of navigating back and forth between
these classes
yeah it's wide it's widened divisions
between the richest and the poorest i
believe jeff bezos for example um
has added something like you know a
multiple to his to his total wealth
while well plenty of other people just
just went under
and i wanted mary do you think
historically this is surprising i mean
ultimately you i suppose might expect
right or wrong and i think when you say
wrong that the rich will be the people
who manage to have the you know the
least harmed under them in a crisis
often and will be the ones who have the
options when it comes to whether it's a
private island or you know getting away
from something or just making your own
surroundings much more pleasant
i think that's absolutely true you know
it's
i thought the the famous you know the
the rich do what they want or the rich
do what they can and the poor suffer
what they must i think is that as the
famous saying has it
um and that's probably always been the
case but what i really wanted to draw
out in this article was the way that
there's a sort of tragedy at work um in
in terms of how this has played out
within the sort of middling sword the
middle class
um which
um which has been
undergoing a process of hollowing out
which is which has been detectable not
just in america but across the west for
for some years really since the the
thatcher years
and then the the the economic liberal
the well the the liberalization of
finance and the industrialization the
migraine outsourcing of industry
um
all of which has has begun a slow
methodical breaking down of middle class
prosperity and to and to a significant
extent working-class prosperity as well
across the west in a way which is is is
now increasingly starting
to reveal itself as a very much very
very much starker and more stratified
stratified plus hierarchy you know
across all of these across all of these
geographies where um
moving back and forth across these class
barriers is just considerably more
difficult and what i what i really
wanted to draw out was the irony of
where the resistance is coming from in
the west to to this
to masking and pandemic control measures
because a lot of it is actually coming
from a sort of the the an older a more
old-fashioned conservative bourgeoisie
many of whom were also
also right behind the economic reforms
which have which have ended up hollowing
out a lot of the sort of middle class
prosperity
um
which is now being replaced by by this
very much more sort of information-led
zoom class um and much and much thinner
middle class
um whereas increasingly on both sides as
joel copkin points out also in in the
january issue um
instead we're seeing something very much
more like a new feudalism
you mentioned the narrowing of the
middle class so if you have the zoom
class and you're talking about the the
laptop class you can ultimately
go where they want to do or perhaps
aspire to live the lifestyles you talk
about of the you know the upper classes
the gettys and what's happening to those
who no longer fit into that middle class
um
where do they know fit is is that
working class or something else
i mean these these things are obviously
complex and vary a lot by geography but
but i suppose you could you could
characterize
you could characterize a lot of what's
happening and a lot of what's happening
in the culture war particularly as a
contest between
you know this sort of emerging zoom
class you know the the knowledge class
with the with a portable ish laptop work
that can happen from anywhere in a much
more place based bourgeoisie you know
which which might be characterized by
you know small business owners for
example or or people connect people
whose
whose prosperity is connected to a
particular geography
such as you know small holders
landowners um small business owners
um
people
who you might characterize i suppose is
a sort of
a sort of old-fashioned yeomanry and
that's the class which is shrinking
um and that's and that's the class that
you find lined up behind behind figures
such as donald trump you know with you
know a certain amount of incoherence um
in in in their argument and and a
certain number you know that
and that brings a certain a number of
contradictions to the fall but but i
think what what we're looking at is a is
a genuine set of class grievances and a
genuine sense of threat at an economic
at a whole sort of economic order and
way of life which is becoming
increasingly increasingly unstable and
is and is being contested by an emerging
new variant of the middle class which
just doesn't have the same commitments
to place
and and has has a wholly different set
of economic interests and i think those
those tensions are really only just
starting to play out and just finally
and on this week's episode we've been
talking a lot about boris johnson the
trouble the government is in and it all
plays into this narrative that we saw
with dominic cummings and barnard castle
of one rule for them and it's been a
really corrosive political narrative in
lots of countries you've seen it in
various governments but i wonder when
we're going back to these mask rules and
talking about the wedding kim
kardashian's holiday
are we just doing a more sophisticated
version of this because there's not so
much of breach of the rules it's almost
a new set of rules um the rules almost
designed to allow for this inequality
i certainly don't think that's how
ordinary people perceive it um
i'm not if i'm honest i mean i couldn't
i couldn't really speculate but my hunch
is it's unlikely to be even how um
our political leaders see it you know
it's it's
i suspect that some form of masking
rituals and class stratifications will
persist but in terms of our immediate
political situation my gut feel is that
actually what's going on is something
more like um they've they've decided
people have more or less consciously
decided that the pandemic is over or
it's nearly over
and they'd like to pin as much of the
collective misery of the british public
and then everything we've all undergone
over the last year and a half or two
years onto boris johnson as possible and
to designate him as it were as a kind of
sin eater and just to to pin blame as
much of that on him as possible and then
load him up with the outrage that comes
you know attendant on the fact that he
has wasn't even really following the
rules himself and then defenestrate him
so that somebody with relatively clean
hands can be installed you know
certainly if i were a tory politician
that's what i'd be doing um if i wanted
to have a have a fighting chance of
winning the next election
and so i i don't really think there's
anything anything sort of large scale
going on about public manners i suspect
it's much more about just politics
thank you mary and thanks for joining us
today
that's it for this week if you enjoyed
this episode don't forget to subscribe
to the spectators youtube channel just
click the subscribe button at the bottom
of this video and tap the bell icon so
you never miss an episode thanks for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
you